[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend und sorry für den
stimmungswechsel wir machen die
nachrichten nicht mehr berichten sie nur
und da ist es normalerweise leider so
dass in der korona lage sich
alarmstimmung breitmacht wieder wurden
dem robert-koch-institut so viele
neuinfektionen gemeldet wie an den
höchsten stellen vor einem jahr und der
trend nach oben scheint ungebrochen
heute
34.000 und zwei neue infektionen heute
kaum weniger als beim rekordwert gestern
und mehr als anderthalb mal so viel wie
am letzten samstag und dabei sind bayern
thüringen und sachsen am schlimmsten
betroffen
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
hat aus einem landesparteitag ohnehin
heute schwierige zahlen zu erklären bei
den letzten beiden bundestagswahlen ist
die sachsen-cdu von 117 auf jetzt sieben
abgeordnete abgestürzt und das ist
allein schon verhängnisvoll für eine
partei und nun kommen sorgen dazu bei
denen es um leben und tod geht in großen
zahlen und da steht dann keinen
sündenbock wie laschet zur verfügung das
ist ein problem für die landesregierung
andere werden folgen thomas bärsch
berichtet aus dresden auch die
aufarbeitung ihrer wahlniederlage wollte
die cdu in sachsen heute auf ihren
parteitag fort führen doch corona
dominierte fast den ganzen tag die
dynamik der neuinfektionen und ihr
gleich lang mit der niedrigen im frater
ließen einen ministerpräsidenten ans
pult treten dem offenbar langsam der
geduldsfaden zu reißen droht angesichts
der immer gleichen diskussion mit
impfverweigerer nein es gibt keinen
impfzwang und es wird auch keinen geben
aber meine damen und herren es kann auch
keinen zwang geben dass diejenigen die
nicht unmittelbar die betroffenen sind
die also eine ganz geringe incidents
haben für die eine corona erkrankung nur
ein normales lebensrisiko ist mit ganz
ganz ganz geringer wahrscheinlichkeit im
krankenhaus zu landen und auf jeden fall
nicht mit der wahrscheinlichkeit die
krankenhaus- und its kapazitäten zu
überlassen dass diese leute jetzt
zwangsweise in ein loch down geschickt
werden gemeinsam mit kindern und
jugendlichen und deswegen müssen wir an
dieser ansetzen die botschaft in sachsen
wird es für ungeimpfte auch zunehmend
ungemütlich so bild ab montag hier in
vielen bereichen zweig und das ist neu
das will die politik dann tatsächlich
auch umsetzen und ja auch kontrollieren
es gibt seit gestern eine allahs lage
das kann man doch offen benennen dass es
auch kooperations teams aus
gesundheitsamt ordnungsamt und polizei
gibt und diesen vollzug in den
landkreisen und kreisfreien städten zu
verzückt das gehört dazu eine wahlkampf
nachlese hat er sich mancher auch von
gast markus söder erhofft doch selbst
mitreißendste marsch rhythmen zündeten
heute nicht so recht für die einen kommt
hier der mit dem sie die bundestagswahl
vielleicht gewonnen hätten für die
anderen geben der den wahlkampf durch
zwischenrufe gestört hat söder selbst
scheint so gar keine lust auf solche
feinheiten zu haben schwamm drüber und
basta aber eines muss klar sein wenn wir
jetzt die nächsten zwei jahre damit
verbringen verbringen uns nur die ganze
zeit zur natur ist doch damals und tut
es doch damals und du sowieso dann
glaube ich persönlich dann erwecken wir
den eindruck einer familie die kein
mensch zum essen einlädt niemand nicht
alle der delegierten im saal sehen das
ganze locker aber fast alle bemühen sich
um neuanfangs esprit ich denke man kann
sich jetzt auch wieder neues sortieren
und es gibt immer neuen anfang ich sag
mal kein aufgeben richtig finde ich auch
dass man gleich von anfang an gesagt hat
wir gehen der opposition und worten
nicht nur tiere sondern wir gucken jetzt
die oppositionelle rolle irgendwie
auszufüllen am ende bestätigte die
partei ihren landesvorsitzenden das aber
mit gerade mal 76 prozent und das ist
dann doch mehr als nur eine überraschung
es scheint als habe die cdu sachsen doch
noch redebedarf
und deutschlands corona politik hat
entscheidungsbedarf die forderungen nach
impfpflicht mindestens für beschäftigte
in kranken- und altenpflege werden
lauter und in sachsen gilt ab montag an
vielen stellen die so genannte 2g riegel
das heißt nur geimpfte und genesene
dürfen rein tests bringen nichts mehr
praktisch ist das ein shutdown
für ungeimpfte bei der
weltklimakonferenz in glasgow ist heute
halbzeitpause einmal durchschnaufen für
zehntausende delegierte und ihr gefolge
halbzeit heißt die zeit der großen
fensterreden der staats- und
regierungschef ist vorbei jetzt geht es
an die eigentliche arbeit und wenn es
greifbare ergebnisse gibt dann entstehen
die jetzt oder eben die aktivisten aus
aller welt erinnern noch einmal daran
dass sie den durchblick haben und lehre
formelkompromisse nicht durchgehen
lassen marco groh und volker
angriffsberichten
rückenblockade in glasgow für mehr
klimaschutz wenn forschung und fakten
nicht reichen soll es ein bisschen
drastischer sein so die idee dieser
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von century belgien
absolut nichts gebracht hat in der
vergangenheit so lange co2 wert in der
atmosphäre steigen friedlich und weniger
drastisch der protest von zehntausenden
heute in der innenstadt auf sie fordern
mehr tempo
ich habe vier kinder und sechs
enkelkinder und ich will absolut
sichergehen dass der planet noch hier
und nachhaltig für sie ist und
hier sitzen die den klimaschutz
voranbringen sollen die erste woche der
weltklimakonferenz ist vorbei anfangs
war die atmosphäre konstruktiv jetzt hat
das große taktieren begonnen eine
durststrecke
das nennen wir in den verhandlungen auf
das tal des todes das heißt wo es jetzt
richtig schwierig wird und wo man in
einigen tagen sehen wird ob dann
kompromisse den weg dort herausführen
lang ist der zeitplan für die meetings
und es geht um viele details nun
kristallisieren sich drei wesentliche
noch offene punkte heraus das sind
solide regeln für internationale
klimaschutz kooperationen die stockende
finanzierung für entwicklungsländer
solle in gang kommen und transparenz
mechanismen müssen abgeschlossen werden
wichtig denn sie sollen sicherstellen
dass überall auf der welt der
treibhausgas-ausstoß nachvollziehbar und
nach gleichen verfahren ermittelt wird
verhandelt werden die mechanismen
in diesem 80 seitigen text in paris
haben wir uns vereinbart dass alle
staaten ihre ziele selber bestimmen und
dann nach gleichen formaten darüber
berichten und diese formate haben wir
jetzt
abseits der verhandlungen schmiedet die
britische regierung eifrig länder
partnerschaften aktuell für den
naturschutz vor allem ging es aber um
den kohleausstieg 190 staaten und
organisationen bekannten sich dazu
bisher aber noch ohne umsetzungs
garantie wir erwarten dass am ende
dieser konferenz hier ein überprüfungs
rahmen beschlossen wird damit man dem
wirklich auf den zahn fühlen kann man
muss wissen ist dass ernst ist das
greenwashing das ziel bleibt die
erderwärmung auf 1,5 grad zu begrenzen
noch reichen dafür weder maßnahme noch
klimaziele aus die kommende woche wird
zeigen ob es gelingt die noch offenen
punkte des pariser klimaschutzabkommens
endlich abzuarbeiten das wäre dann
zumindest ein teilerfolg und in der tat
zeichnet sich ein globaler trend ab aus
der kohleverstromung auszusteigen
allerdings kann das nur funktionieren
wenn zeitgleich entsprechend große
mengen erneuerbarer also sauberer
energien zur verfügung stehen auch sie
werden genau auf das konferenz geschehen
schauen und sobald sie wieder frei sind
denn für brücken blockaden hat die
polizei hier wenig verständnis
die nachrichten beginnen mit einem
ereignis heute über das wir zu wenig
wissen um schon ausführlich zurück bei
dem messerangriff in einem ic gehen die
ermittler derzeit nicht von einem
terroranschlag aus hintergründe und
motiv der tat sind noch unklar ein 27
jähriger syrer hatte mit einem messer
drei mitreisende schwer verletzt der
mann konnte überwältigt und festgenommen
werden
2014 war er als flüchtling nach
deutschland gekommen lebte zuletzt in
passau die kripo regensburg ermittelt
wegen versuchter tötungsdelikte
dabei werden auch psychische probleme
des täters untersucht die bahnstrecke
regensburg nürnberg war den ganzen tag
über
sperrt das private rettungsschiff iphone
darf nun doch in italien anlegen die
behörden erlaubten die fahrt in den
hafen von trapani auf sizilien sowie
hilfsorganisation dc iphone hatte in den
vergangenen tagen im mittelmeer bei
verschiedenen einsätzen mehr als 800
menschen an bord genommen unter ihnen
viele kinder und jugendliche
das schiff wird den hafen
voraussichtlich morgen nachmittag
erreichen
mindestens acht tote und mehr als 300
verletzte das ist die tragische bilanz
einer massenpanik bei einem
musikfestival im texanischen houston
während des auftritts des rappers travis
scott war es vor der bühne zu einem
dichten gedränge gekommen panik brach
aus augenzeugen berichten von einer
aggressiven stimmung viele der opfer
sollen sehr jung gewesen sein einige
erst 14 jahre alt nach monatelangem
ringen hat der us kongress ein
infrastrukturpaket im umfang von mehr
als einer billion dollar verabschiedet
und damit ein zentrales
wahlkampfversprechen von präsident biden
umgesetzt mit hilfe des pakets sollen
straßen modernisiert und
internetleitungen ausgebaut werden für
sein zweites großes vorhaben
investitionen in klimaschutz und
sozialleistungen muss beiden weiterhin
kämpfen die zeiten in denen sich
deutschen touristen über amerikas
bröckelnde infrastruktur in weltstädten
wie new york chicago los angeles lustig
machen konnten ist vorbei nicht weil es
in den usa schon so viel besser geworden
wäre sondern weil europas land der
ingenieure und erfinder die eigenen
verkehrswege hat verrotten lassen peter
theißen sieht in der spektakulären
sprengung einer unrettbar gewordenen
brücke heute in der landeshauptstadt von
hessen das große ganze
letzte kontrollfahrt durch die
angrenzenden wohngebiete 140 menschen
müssen die sperrzone im radius von 250
metern um die brücke verlassen bloß kein
risiko 220 kilogramm sprengstoff sollen
gleich in die luft gehen
pünktlich um 12 uhr ein lauter knall
dann ist sie weg die salzbach talbrücke
nur noch schutt und staub das marode
bauwerk auch ein symbol für die
vernachlässigte infrastruktur in
deutschland
es ist das erklärte sie dass wir in
deutschland keine zweite salzbach
talbrücke bekommen als das ereignis darf
sich nicht wiederholen
im juni waren betonbrocken von der
autobahnbrücke abgebrochen und
heruntergestürzt die fahrbahn senkte
sich um 30 zentimeter sperrung der
wichtigen brücke teilstück der a 66 und
auch die darunterliegenden gleise
konnten nicht mehr genutzt werden ein
supergau für den verkehr des
rhein-main-gebiets unsere brücken sind
offen gesagt in die jahre gekommen
gerade die in westdeutschland wurden in
der regel so vor etwa 50 jahren gebaut
teilweise auch etwas früher und die
wurden halt auch für einen verkehr
geplant den es heute den wir heute weit
übertroffen haben in den 60er jahren
lief der verkehr auf den autobahnen noch
viel gemächlicher die lkw bahn erheblich
leichter als heute viele brücken sind
dem nicht mehr gewachsen nach dem jahr
2000 wurde außerdem beim erhalt der
infrastruktur der rotstift angesetzt ein
beispiel die leverkusener brücke der a 1
sie machte von neun jahren als erstes
prominentes beispiel schlapp gerade
werden dutzende brücken saniert oder
müssen sogar neu gebaut werden
wie ein bisher rund 200 autobahnbrücken
sogar ein bisschen weniger pro jahr in
ordnung gebracht und wir werden in
zukunft rund 400 autobahnbrücken pro
jahr in ordnung bringen müssen das
bedeutet eine erhöhung der dazu
notwendigen personellen und materiellen
und auch finanziellen ressourcen das
zweite ist wir müssen natürlich im
bereich der planungs beschleunigung noch
einiges nachschärfen wir müssen hier
schneller werden gerade auch im bereich
von ersatz ersatz neubau von brücken und
das dritte ist dass wir auch andere
bauverfahren an den tag legen können die
bauindustrie hat hier viele lösungen
gerade im bereich des seriellen
brückenbaus hier können wir viel
schneller brücken erstellen als wir das
heute in sechs bis acht monaten gewohnt
sind
in wiesbaden sollen die 15.000 tonnen
schutt und schnell beiseite geschafft
werden damit wenigstens bis weihnachten
wieder züge nach wiesbaden rollen können
die neue autobahnbrücke aber wird
frühestens 2023 befahrbar sein
der österreicher clemens johann setz hat
die bedeutendste literaturauszeichnung
im deutschsprachigen raum erhalten den
georg büchner preis der 38 jährige sei
ein sprachkünstler der grenzbereiche
erkunde so die deutsche akademie für
sprache und dichtung setzt schreibt
romane erzählungen gedichte und
theaterstücke
er studierte germanistik und mathematik
und gilt als literarisches wunderkind
gleich zum wetter zunächst die
gewinnzahlen vom lotto sie lauten ohne
gewähr 69 27 31 41 44 superzahl 9
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 das
novemberwetter bleibt trübe allerdings
bringt das aktuelle tief im osten
deutschlands nicht nur recht viel regen
sondern auch schnee
den westlichen mittelgebirgen wie hier
im fichtelgebirge weil sonne und blauem
himmel einfach schön und gelegenheit für
erste wintersport aktivitäten
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen und in
den alpen kann es auch in den nächsten
tagen schneien sonnig ist es morgen nur
am alpenrand
sonst wird es wechselnd oder stark
bewölkt vor allem im norden gibt es
viele schauer örtlich gewitter bei teils
stürmischem westwind und fünf bis zwölf
grad am montag regnet es noch etwas
sonst ruhiges novemberwetter mit einer
mischung aus etwas sonne nebel und
vielen wolken bei sechs bis zwölf grad
und nun ist vor zweieinhalb minuten
diese sendung zum gestern journal
geworden und ich erfolgt nun der sport
vom samstag als erste sendung am
sonntagmorgen sind wir wieder pünktlich
da bisher schon in st
[Musik]